desserts for kids the carrots the
dessert we are trying McDonald's in
Israel right now I'm not a huge cheese
burger person so I think it'll be better
okay I'm a pretty big McDonald's fan in
general I think it's the best of the
fast-food these are corn state you know
I have this in America it looks a little
bit like mini mozzarella sticks inside
there's corn and mashed potatoes or
something I'm a little worried because
it has a real corn pieces in it I love
porn I believe corn bread all day it's
sweet and savory and I'm a big sweet and
savory person those are pretty good it
tastes like a coconut god I wonder
what's inside cuz I don't think it's
cheese total boy I do not see what this
is I'm trying the Texas sauce smells
like barbecue so this is what is really
sink Texan to preoccupy tastes like
barbecue sauce House I seriously really
guns I'm trying to match against a Big
Mac or my mastermind
Israel's a tech country it's like iMac
my back this is as big as my face it's
huge
it looks really similar to what we have
but I have Satine any sauce on it
everything it's got like two crispy
chickens in it yeah this is good it
tastes like chickens on are on a bun you
don't really taste this tahini sauce
we'd really know how to do fried chicken
in America this Fried chicken's like
crispy and nice but it's not like fried
chicken
you know kind of bland actually I think
it's better than chicken this is
apparently what Israelis think Americans
eat all the time because this is called
the mega big america las vegas edition
I'm from Las Vegas very big fattie
okay beside me here looks like an entire
steak it's got kind of weird granular
stuff going on nice tomatoes lettuce
it's just like me honestly I'm not being
meteor but that's good it's really too
soon
it's super dry super well about the
texture of the meats kind of somewhere
between hammer groundstake grape
tomatoes McDonald's good to go
these really make films with more or
less the same I see Mary Thomas pretty
good just like regular because I
definitely get these again corn Spencer
best so I give it a a plus - the corn
sticks woody if it weren't for all the
other great food
[Music]
hey unsolved was on a new channel
subscribe here that was my part